This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. What's up, fam, it's sports journalist Ari Chambers. Hey, what's up, y'all? It's your girl, Sam J. And we're the hosts of Everyone Watches Women's Sports, a new podcast from Together. We're breaking down the biggest headlines,
这是一个iHeart播客。百分之百真人。大家好，我是体育记者阿里·钱伯斯。嘿，大家好！我是你们的女孩萨姆·J。我们是《每个人都在看女子体育》的主持人，这是Together推出的全新播客。我们将剖析最重要的头条新闻、
the viral moments, and the stories everyone's talking about across women's sports. From game-changing performances to culture-shifting conversations, we'll give you our takes, our debates, and a few laughs along the way. Because everyone watches women's sports.
病毒式传播的时刻，以及女子体育界所有人都在热议的故事。从改变比赛表现的时刻到颠覆文化的对话，我们将分享我们的观点、辩论，并带给你一路上的欢笑。因为每个人都在看女子体育。
Listen to everyone watches women's sports. on the iHeartRadio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello, everybody. Welcome back to the show.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《每个人都在看女子体育》。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨你二十多岁时经历的最大变化、时刻和转型，以及它们对我们心理学的意义。大家好，欢迎回到节目中。
Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of your 20s. today I have a very special episode for you all, basically an hour of free therapy. A huge focus of this podcast is mental health and it's psychology. Psychology is in the name and we talk about so many concepts and theories, even therapeutic practices and interventions. We talk about it all the time.
欢迎回到本播客。非常高兴你能来到这里，收听又一期节目，当然，我们要在这里剖析你二十多岁的心理学。今天我为你们准备了一期非常特别的节目，基本上就是一小时的免费心理治疗。本播客的一个核心重点是心理健康及其心理学。心理学就写在名字里，我们讨论了如此多的概念和理论，甚至还有治疗实践和干预措施。我们一直在讨论这些。
But what I have never done is just sat down and done a full episode on what therapy actually is, what it aims to do, what it means to be a therapist, what it means to be a therapist, what it means to be in therapy, everybody tells us that it's helpful. Everybody tells us it's this magical thing. Why? Why just talking to a stranger help? What can you expect? Why does it change people?
但我从未做过的是，坐下来做一整期节目，探讨心理治疗到底是什么，它的目的是什么，成为一名心理治疗师意味着什么，接受心理治疗意味着什么。每个人都告诉我们这很有用。每个人都告诉我们这是一件神奇的事情。为什么？为什么仅仅跟一个陌生人说话就能有帮助？你能期待什么？为什么它能改变人？
So in this episode, we're going to break down exactly what therapy does, the real psychology behind why change happens, and what it means to be a therapist, what it means to go to therapy. We're also bringing on a very special guest, Dr. Sandra Espinoza. She is the associate professor. and the former branch director for the couple and family therapy program at Alliant University. She's going to share some amazing expertise with us today. Dr. Espinosa, welcome to the show.
所以在本期节目中，我们将详细剖析心理治疗的作用、发生改变背后的真实心理学，以及成为一名心理治疗师意味着什么，去接受心理治疗意味着什么。我们还邀请了一位非常特别的嘉宾，桑德拉·埃斯皮诺萨博士。她是联合大学（Alliant University）伴侣与家庭治疗专业的副教授兼前分校主任。她今天将与我们分享一些惊人的专业知识。埃斯皮诺萨博士，欢迎来到本节目。
Thank you so much for having me, Jemma. I'm excited to be here. Yeah, I'm so excited to have you here. Do you want to introduce yourself and just talk about the work that you do at Alliance and also be on? Because you do some cool stuff. Sure. Yeah, so I am an associate professor at Alliant University. I have been at Alliance now for, I think,
非常感谢邀请我，杰玛。很高兴来到这里。是的，很高兴你能来。你想不想自我介绍一下，顺便谈谈你在联合大学以及在其他地方所做的工作？因为你做了一些很酷的事情。当然可以。好的，我是联合大学的副教授。我在联合大学工作了大概，我想有
10 years and I have been a therapist for about 13, I think going on 14. So I'm a clinician and an educator. I have a really small private practice where I see clients and I see mostly couples as well as a lot of women and a lot of clients that identify as immigrants. So I have my clinical work. I have my teaching, I do some research, and then I think the part that brings the most meaning to my work is that I'm also an organizer for a volunteer group of therapists who donate their time to serving immigrants, specifically undocumented immigrants, and I've been organizing for that for the past year. So there are folks who are just, again, donating their time to provide therapy for people who might not have access to it otherwise. And that has just been a really exciting and meaningful part
10年了，我做心理治疗师大约有13年，快14年了。所以我既是一名临床医生，也是一名教育工作者。我有一个非常小的私人诊所，我在那里接待客户，主要是伴侣，还有很多女性以及许多认同为移民的客户。所以我有我的临床工作，我有教学，我做一些研究，然后我认为给我的工作带来最多意义的部分是，我也为一组心理治疗师志愿者担任组织者，他们捐出自己的时间来为移民服务，特别是无证移民，在过去的一年里我一直在组织这项工作。所以这些人只是，再次强调，捐出他们的时间，为那些可能无法以其他方式获得心理治疗的人提供治疗。这确实是我职业生涯中非常令人兴奋和有意义的一部分，
of my career the past year. I'm also a mom. I am a mom of three. I have three little kids. I have a five-year-old, a three-year-old, and a six-month-old. So I know. So I have my hands full with that. And I am Mexican-American. I am a proud daughter of immigrants. And so I'm bilingual. And I speak Spanish. And so just really passionate about doing clinical work with the Latinx community. I'm that is so impressive but also a double thanks for being here today because you have a lot of other stuff probably is a little bit more important but I honestly feel like that was why I really wanted to speak to you because you've just done so much over so many different so many different parts of like the psychology discipline and the therapy discipline and like what you can do and how you can help at every single
在过去的一年里。我也是一位妈妈。我是三个孩子的妈妈。我有三个小孩子。我有一个五岁的孩子、一个三岁的孩子和一个六个月大的婴儿。所以我知道。所以我的手头有很多事情要忙。我是墨西哥裔美国人。我是移民的骄傲女儿。所以我是双语的。我讲西班牙语。因此，我真的热衷于为拉丁裔社区开展临床工作。这太令人印象深刻了，同时也要双重感谢你今天能来，因为你可能还有很多其他事情，那些事也许更重要一点，但我真的觉得这就是我为什么特别想跟你对话的原因，因为你在心理学学科和治疗学科的许多不同领域、许多不同部分都做了如此多的事情，以及你可以做什么，如何在每一个层面提供帮助，
level and a lot of our listeners are doing psychology, want to become therapists or just in general trying to figure out who they want to become. You specifically, what did your journey into this field actually look like? Like, did you come into it? Did you always know this is what you wanted to be doing? Give us a look through. Yeah, sure. So when I was in my undergrad, I was really interested in working with kids and working kind of more in the education field. And so I worked in a lot of after-school programs. I read for the Boys and Girls Club. I did AmeriCorps.
并且我们的许多听众正在学习心理学，想成为治疗师，或者只是在总体上试图弄清楚他们想成为什么样的人。具体到你，你进入这个领域的旅程实际上是什么样的？你是怎么接触到它的？你一直都知道这是你想做的事情吗？带我们了解一下吧。好的，没问题。所以当我在读本科时，我真的对与儿童合作以及更多地在教育领域工作感兴趣。因此我参加了很多课后辅导项目。我为男孩女孩俱乐部做过阅读辅导。我做过美国国家青年服务队（AmeriCorps）。
And that work was really meaningful. And I, you know, I still carry so many of the, like, amazing memories that I made in working with children. But what I noticed as that when I was working with the kids, you know, a lot of them came from some challenging backgrounds. And even though they had these amazing programs that they were attending with me after school, I didn't feel like it was enough to really make an impact in their. lives. I would, you know, I could spend two, three hours with them after school, but then they would
那项工作非常有意义。而且，你知道，我依然带着在与孩子们一起工作时创造的那么多惊人的美好回忆。但我注意到的是，当我与孩子们一起工作时，你知道，他们中的许多人都有着一些充满挑战的背景。尽管他们和我一起参加了这些课后他们参加的精彩项目，但我觉得这还不足以真正对他们的生活产生影响。你知道，我可以在课后花两、三个小时陪他们，但随后他们
kind of go back home to sometimes homes that didn't have a lot of resources, homes where the parent relationship wasn't great. And I kept asking myself, like, what more can I do? I would spend weekends with them, take them on field trips, and I still kept coming across this, like, I don't know, just kind of inner challenge of like, I need to be doing more. I want to help in another way. And so then I started researching different programs, different schools, and a friend had always told me, you need to go to Alliant. Alliance trains a really good therapist. You need to go, look into it. So I started looking into Alliance. And then from there, I came across the couple in family therapy program. And I was like,
有时会回到那些没有太多资源、父母关系不是很好的家庭。我一直在问自己，我还能做些什么？我会和他们一起度过周末，带他们去实地考察，但我仍然不断遇到这种，我不知道，某种内心的挑战，觉得：我需要做更多。我想以另一种方式提供帮助。于是我开始研究不同的项目、不同的学校，有个朋友一直对我说，你需要去联合大学。联合大学培养出非常优秀的治疗师。你得去，了解一下。所以我开始了解联合大学。从那里，我接触到了伴侣与家庭治疗专业，当时我就想：
yes, I want to work with families. I want to work with couples because I want to make that larger impact with the children that I'm serving. And what's the best way to reach a child? It's through their parent. It's through their family. I also had, I think, pretty, I came from a really good family, I will say. My family, you know, my parents were supportive. They sacrificed a lot for me. But I had a lot of trouble with my romantic relationships growing up and I think didn't, just didn't have like a blueprint for what to do in a couple's relationship. And so I mentioned this part because I think that also inspired me to go specifically into like couple work where I think I wanted answers. So like, why aren't my romantic relationships working? And so it was like both.
是的，我想和家庭一起工作。我想和伴侣一起工作，因为我想对我服务的儿童产生更广泛的影响。而接触一个孩子最好的方式是什么？是通过他们的父母。是通过他们的家庭。我想我也曾有过，可以这么说，来自一个非常好的家庭。我的家庭，你知道，我的父母很支持我。他们为我牺牲了很多。但在我成长过程中，我在恋爱关系中遇到了很多麻烦，而且我认为，就是没有关于在伴侣关系中该怎么做的蓝图。我提到这一点是因为我认为这也激发了我专门从事伴侣工作，当时我想寻找答案。也就是：为什么我的恋爱关系没有起色？所以两者兼而有之。
It was like, I want to work with families. I want to make that impact. And then also I kind of want to find out more about myself, about relationships, like what makes a healthy relationship, what makes it work. So I think it was a combination of both of those things. Honestly, I feel like the best therapists are the ones who have had like tangible experiences themselves so they can like see somebody come into their office and and just know where that sits kind of in the soul and in the body and in the mind. Something I want to ask you, maybe this is a personal question. Before becoming a therapist, did you go to therapy yourself?
就像是：我想和家庭一起工作。我想产生那种影响。然后我也想更多地了解我自己、关于关系，比如什么造就了健康的关系，什么让它发挥作用。所以我认为这是这两件事情的结合。老实说，我觉得最好的治疗师就是那些自己有过切实经历的人，这样他们就能看到有人走进他们的办公室，并且清楚地知道那种感受在心灵、身体和思想中处于什么位置。我想问你一个问题，也许这是一个个人问题。在成为治疗师之前，你自己接受过心理治疗吗？
No. No. And this is very embarrassing because I tell all my students, like you have to go to therapy before becoming a therapist. And I think we'll probably dive into a little bit more of like why that's so much. important later. But I'll mention it kind of like briefly here. You know, when you are doing this work with other people, it's so important that you have fully examined, right, your own biases, values, belief systems, et cetera, so that when you are in a therapeutic relationship with somebody
没有。没有。这非常尴尬，因为我告诉我的所有学生，在你成为治疗师之前，你必须去接受心理治疗。我想我们稍后可能会更深入地探讨为什么这如此重要。但我在这里先简要提一下。当你与其他人一起做这项工作时，非常重要的一点是，你必须已经完全审视过，对吧，你自己的偏见、价值观、信仰体系等等，这样当你与某人建立治疗关系时，
else, you are making sure that those things aren't transcending into the relationship with the other, that you are, you have fixed your, you have figured out yourself so well, right, right? at least in some ways, to make sure that when you are, how to, where do I, counseling somebody else, like that that isn't informing the way that you do it. I'll give you an example. Some people are still carrying such deep wounds about, again, their own couple relationship, that they'll then start working with a couple and side with one partner because that's what resonates more personally to them in terms of their lived experience.
别人，你要确保这些事情不会延续到与对方的关系中，你要确保，你已经把你自己修理好了，你对自己了解得如此透彻，对吧？至少在某些方面，为了确保当你，怎么说呢，在哪里，在辅导别人时，那不会影响你做事的方式。我给你举个例子。有些人仍然怀揣着如此深刻的创伤，关于，再次强调，他们自己的伴侣关系，以至于他们开始与一对伴侣合作时，会偏袒其中一方，因为就他们的生活经历而言，那对他们个人更有共鸣。
And so we want folks to go to therapy first to make sure that that doesn't happen, that you are trying your best, right, to remain as neutral as possible, even though neutrality is also impossible because all of us are bringing in our own lived experiences as therapists. We want to be able to remain impartial, right? We want to have what we call in like contextual therapies, like multi-directive partiality that we're able to hear every single person out. We're not citing, right, et cetera. But back to your original question of like, did I? ever go. No, I think that it was really taboo in my family. My parents definitely didn't go to therapy. Again, they were like immigrants. They came from Mexico. They didn't speak English. It just wasn't talked about in my family. And it was only until I became a therapist and started doing the work that then
所以我们希望人们先去接受心理治疗，以确保这种情况不会发生，确保你正在尽最大努力，对吧，尽可能保持中立，尽管中立也是不可能的，因为我们所有人作为治疗师都带着我们自己的生活经历。我们希望能够保持公正，对吧？我们希望拥有我们在语境治疗中称之为“多向偏向”（multi-directed partiality）的东西，即我们能够倾听每一个人的心声。我们没有偏袒，等等。但回到你最初的问题：我以前去过吗？没有。我认为这在我家里绝对是个禁忌。我的父母绝对没有去接受过心理治疗。同样，他们就像移民。他们来自墨西哥。他们不会说英语。这在我家里根本不被谈论。直到我成为一名治疗师并开始从事这项工作，然后
finally I went. I went to individual therapy. I've been to couples therapy. And now I'm like, oh my God, I should have done this so much sooner. It would have helped before even becoming a therapist in a lot of ways. I really like that that's the advice that you give to your students because you're like, I did it the other way. And so now, like, I'm not going to say, like, don't make the same mistakes, but it's like, I know I can see that I would have been aided through this. And it must have been, yeah, it must have been difficult.
我才终于去了。我去做了个体心理治疗。我去过伴侣心理治疗。现在我想：天哪，我应该早得多这么做的。在很多方面，甚至在成为治疗师之前，这就会对我有所帮助。我真的很喜欢这是你给学生的建议，因为你就像是在说：我是以另一种方式走过来的。所以现在，就像，我不会说，呃，不要犯同样的错误，而是说：我知道，我可以看出我曾经会如何通过这种方式得到帮助。并且那一定，是的，对你来说一定很困难，
Oh, not difficult, but interesting for you, like becoming a therapist and maybe never having experienced therapy. And I know so many people listening to this believe to their call. Like, therapy is an amazing thing. I really like it's great but I've just never done it. So there is this specific idea of therapy is like lying on a couch, being maybe like ask questions about your dreams, about your parents. What do you actually do in therapy? Yeah. Well, that is also such a big question because depending on who you're asking, you're going to get a different response. So if you were interviewing a psychiatrist, a psychologist, a psychologist, a socialist, a socialist, a socialist, a socialist, a socialist, a social worker, an MFT like me, you're going to get a different response probably from each person. And that's because we all do it or approach it in different ways. Right. So for us, as a couple and family therapists, we are working with an individual and trying to figure out what their inner world is,
哦，不是困难，但很有趣，作为一个治疗师却可能从未体验过心理治疗。我知道很多听众对此深信不疑。就像，心理治疗是一件了不起的事情。我真的很喜欢，这很棒，但我只是从来没做过。所以有一种关于心理治疗的特定观念，比如躺在沙发上，可能会被问到关于你的梦想、关于你的父母的问题。在心理治疗中，你究竟在做什么？是的。嗯，这也是一个很大的问题，因为取决于你问的是谁，你会得到不同的回答。所以如果你采访精神病学家、心理学家、社会工作者、像我这样的MFT（婚姻与家庭治疗师），你可能会从每个人那里得到不同的回答。那是因为我们所有人做这件事或处理这件事的方式都不同。没错。所以对我们而言，作为伴侣和家庭治疗师，我们正在与个人合作，试图弄清楚他们的内心世界是什么，
right, what their belief systems are, how they're thinking about things, how they're feeling about things, but we're also looking at it in the context of relationships and systems. So yes, we want to understand what you're experiencing, what's hurting you, what's painful, what's bothering you. But how is that being experienced in the relation to your family, in the relation to your neighborhood, in the relation to your society? Because we believe as MFTs that all of those things impact the way that you are navigating the world. And so that's really our emphasis. Whereas if you were to ask, I don't know, a psychologist or a different kinds of
对吧，他们的信仰体系是什么，他们如何思考事物，他们如何感受事物，但我们同时也在关系和系统的语境下来看待它。所以是的，我们想要了解你的经历是什么，什么在伤害你，什么是痛苦的，什么在困扰你。但是，这在与你的家庭、与你的邻里、与你的社会的动态关系中是如何被体验的？因为我们作为MFT相信，所有这些事情都影响着你在这个世界上航行的方式。所以这确实是我们的重点。然而，如果你去问，我不知道，心理学家或不同种类的
therapist, they might say, well, we're really concerned about behavior and helping you modify your behavior so that you have less emotional distress so that you have less anxiety. And that is also valuable, right? So I'm thinking about like people who have like OCD, for example, who really need help managing some of their behaviors so that they experience like symptom relief, right? But again, it just depends on who you're going to ask that you'll get that kind of like different response. But again, I think for me, like where I live as an MFT, it's really about helping a person
治疗师，他们可能会说，嗯，我们真正关切的是行为，并帮助你改变你的行为，这样你的情绪困扰就会减少，这样你的焦虑就会减少。这也是很有价值的，对吧？所以我想到了那些患有强迫症（OCD）的人，例如，他们真正需要帮助来管理他们的一些行为，以便他们体验到症状的缓解，对吧？但话说回来，这完全取决于你问的是谁，你才会得到那种不同的回答。不过再次强调，我认为对我而言，作为一个MFT的立足点，它真正关乎的是帮助一个人
better understand themselves in relation to their family context and their sociopolitical context so that they can make sense of what they're experiencing. I like the emphasis on like how the environment has shaped you in ways that you probably don't understand and how you need to have that baseline. Or maybe do understand, actually, we probably do, but you, you know, need to get to that next layer of depth. Something I want to ask you, because you work with so many different types of people, you know, when you meet someone as a therapist and you're looking into their, you know, their family history, the sociopolitical environment that they're, the sociopolitical environment that they live in, just everything that's going on around them and within them and in their past.
更好地理解自己在家庭语境和社会政治语境中的关系，以便他们能够理解自己正在经历的事情。我喜欢这种强调，即环境是如何以你可能并不理解的方式塑造了你，以及为什么你需要拥有这个基准。或者也许你确实理解，实际上，我们可能确实理解，但你，你知道，需要达到深度的下一个层面。我想问你一件事，因为你与许多不同类型的人合作，你知道，当你作为治疗师遇到某人，并且你在探究他们的，你知道，他们的家庭历史，他们所处的社会政治环境，他们生活的社会政治环境，以及发生在他周围、内心以及他们过去的一切。
Specifically, and maybe this is a difficult question to answer, what are you looking for? What are you trying to figure out about that individual in the first couple of sessions? Yeah, I'm usually trying to look for a pattern. So whether that's where I'm working with an individual, whether I'm working with a couple, or whether or not I'm working with a family, I'm trying to find the pattern that keeps getting them stuck. because most of the time when people are coming to therapy, it's because they want to change something, right? They want something about their lives to be different.
具体来说，也许这是一个很难回答的问题，你在寻找什么？在最初的几次会谈中，你试图弄清楚关于那个个人的什么？是的，我通常试图寻找一种模式。所以无论我是与个人合作，无论我是与伴侣合作，还是与家庭合作，我都在试图找出让他们陷入困境的模式。因为大多数时候，人们来接受心理治疗是因为他们想改变某些东西，对吧？他们希望自己生活的某个方面有所不同。
And many times they're telling me, we keep getting stuck, or I keep getting stuck, I keep dating the same guy over and over again, or we keep fighting about the same exact thing, help us through it. And so my job is to look for that pattern, or we even call it like a cycle or we call it a dance, and figure out how can we interrupt. this pattern so that you have a new way of being in relationship with yourself or others. And that will entail, right, what we just talked about, which is like, okay, looking back at your
很多时候他们会告诉我，我们总是陷入困境，或者我总是陷入困境，我总是和一个又一个相同的家伙约会，或者我们总是为完全相同的事情争吵，帮我们度过难关吧。所以我的工作就是寻找那种模式，或者我们也称之为循环或舞蹈，并弄清楚我们如何能够打断
family, what are some things that you learned about your family, what was passed on, what kind of messages were sent to you about being afraid, about being sad. It might inquire, again, us to look at your, again, sociopolitical context. do you have a real reason to be scared to leave outside of your door, right? How is that also impacting the way that you're showing up in your relationships? What have your past relationships look like just like as a young adult? How is that informing the way that you're showing up in the here and now, right? So a lot of it is looking back at the past, looking at different systems,
这种模式，以便你与自己或他人建立关系时有新的方式。这将需要，对吧，我们刚刚谈到的，也就是，好吧，回过头来看看你的家庭，你从你的家庭中了解到的一些事情是什么，什么被传承了下来，关于恐惧、关于悲伤，向你发送了什么样的信息。它可能还会要求我们审视你的社会政治语境。你是否有真正的理由害怕走出你的家门，对吧？这又是如何影响你在关系中展现自你自己的方式的？作为一个年轻人，你过去的关系是什么样的？这又是如何塑造你在此时此地展现自我的方式的，对吧？所以很大一部分是回望过去，审视不同的系统，
and then tying it back to how is that impacting you? this present moment. Can I ask a question? If you have somebody come in and like you said, you know, they're an immigrant, they're scared to go outside their door or there's somebody who's experienced, I don't know, racism and they're terrified of that happening, how do you handle those like very real environmental things that you can't change as a therapist? Absolutely. I've always, like I just, yeah, I think that's such an interesting thing. Yes. And I think that that is a question that a lot of people ask themselves, even like therapists or like, how do I help this
然后将其与这对你此时此刻的影响联系起来。我可以问个问题吗？如果你有个人进来，就像你说的，他们是个移民，他们害怕走出家门，或者他们是经历过，我不知道，种族主义并且对此感到恐惧的人，作为治疗师，你如何处理那些你无法改变的非常现实的环境因素？绝对的。我一直，就像我，是的，我认为这是一个非常有趣的事情。是的，我认为这也是许多人会问自己的问题，甚至像治疗师也是，我该如何帮助这个
person when I have no control over their environment? And the truth is like first just like naming that, right, and validating that and saying, you are not crazy. There is nothing innately wrong with you. You are having a very normal response to an abnormal situation. And we think about it that way with like any kind of trauma really where a person actually has a real reason to be scared. Maybe they had gotten in a really bad car accident or they've lost a family in a car accident, lost their family in an airplane and they're scared of flying. They're scared of driving. It makes sense to me that people are terrified of doing that thing again.
人，当我根本无法控制他们的环境时？事实是，首先就是去命名它，对吧，去验证它并说：你并没有疯。你身上没有什么天生不对劲的地方。你对一种非正常的情况做出了非常正常的反应。对于任何真正意义上的创伤，我们都是这样看的，即一个人确实有真正的理由感到害怕。也许他们卷入了一场非常严重的车祸，或者他们在车祸中失去了家人，在飞机失事中失去了家人，他们害怕飞行。他们害怕开车。在我看来，人们害怕再次做那件事是合情合理的。
And I think that that is so important to first just like name that you are having again a very normal response to an abnormal situation that shouldn't have happened to you, that shouldn't have happened to your family. And then also again acknowledging that no matter what I do, right, I won't be able to fix what is happening outside of these four walls. However, this is going to be your space where you can talk about these things. I can hear you and I can help you figure out a way to navigate what is happening outside as best as possible. Because I, you know, in a lot of lot of the work that I do, I tell my therapist, you know, if you are feeling frustrated that your client is not getting better, you are feeling like maybe I'm not a good therapist because I can't
我认为首先去命名这一点是非常重要的，即你再次对一种本不该发生在你身上、本不该发生在你家庭身上的非正常情况做出了非常正常的反应。然后再次承认，无论我做什么，对吧，我都无法解决这四堵墙外正在发生的事情。然而，这里将是你的空间，你可以在这里谈论这些事情。我能倾听你，我能帮你尽可能找出应对外面正在发生的事情的方法。因为我，你知道，在我所做的很多工作中，我告诉我的治疗师，你知道，如果你感到沮丧，因为你的客户没有好转，如果你觉得也许我不是一个好治疗师，因为我无法
relieve all of their human suffering. You have to remember that it's not your fault. And a lot of the times we are just dealing with a broken sociopolitical system, right? It's beyond your control. And you just have to trust that your relationship with this person. is enough. And it's going to be enough to make a difference and relieve some of that pain that they are experiencing. I wish I had you as a professor when I was studying psychology. I feel like that's never spoken about of just like you, you have to know your limits as somebody as a helper and as an empath and as somebody just doing their job. Speaking of what makes a good therapist, yeah, what makes a good therapist? Like should you, if somebody is new to therapy
减轻他们所有的苦难。你必须记住，这不是你的错。很多时候，我们只是在处理一个破碎的社会政治系统，对吧？这超出了你的控制范围。你只需要相信你与这个人之间的关系。这就足够了。这将足以产生影响，并减轻他们正在经历的一些痛苦。当我学习心理学时，我真希望有你这样的教授。我觉得人们从来不会谈论这一点，作为一个帮助者、同理心拥有者以及一个只是在做自己工作的人，你必须了解自己的极限。说到什么才是一个好治疗师，是的，什么才是一个好治疗师？如果有人是心理治疗的新手，他们会想：我怎么知道这个人适合我？这个人能帮到我吗？这个人擅长他们的工作吗？但是，我们应该寻找什么以及注意什么？
and they're like, how do I know this person is right for me? Is this person going to help me? Is this person good at their job? But like what do we and should we look out for? Yeah, I think that goes back to what we were talking about earlier in terms of, you know, should you go to therapy before becoming a therapist? And that's really why I highly recommend that because it ties into what makes a good therapist. So I think a good therapist has done a lot of that self-examination prior to,
是的，我认为这可以追溯到我们之前讨论过的问题，即：在成为治疗师之前，你应该去接受心理治疗吗？这正是为什么我强烈推荐这一点的原因，因为它与什么造就了一个好治疗师息息相关。所以我想一个好的治疗师在
becoming a therapist and doing that work, or at least concurrently. One of our requirements in our program is that our students have to complete at least 50 hours of individual psychotherapy while completing their program because the training that we give them brings up so much stuff and so much sometimes like baggage for people that we want to make sure they're kind of like sorting out before they are seeing clients. because, you know, it's impossible to predict what clients bring into the room with you. And the therapist can easily be triggered just as much as the client. A lot of therapists, again, are kind of bringing in their own wounds, family stories, belief systems, religious beliefs, political beliefs.
成为治疗师并做那项工作之前，或者至少在进行训练的同时，已经做了很多自我审视。我们项目的一个要求是，我们的学生在完成项目的过程中必须完成至少50个小时的个体心理治疗，因为我们给他们的培训带来了太多的东西，有时甚至给人们带来很多包袱，我们要确保他们在接待客户之前把这些理清。因为，你知道，你不可能预测客户会把什么带进房间。治疗师很容易被触发，就像客户一样。许多治疗师，再次强调，也在带来他们自己的创伤、家庭故事、信仰体系、宗教信仰、政治信仰。
And if those go unexamined, they can harm. the client relationship. Therapists might recommend a client to do something based on their lived experience, and that might not be what's best for that particular client, right? A good therapist has to be capable of being wrong, right? Just because you have extensive training, that doesn't mean that you're always going to know what's best for your client. Sometimes I even tell students, once you think that you know what's best for your client,
如果这些未经审视，它们可能会损害。客户关系。治疗师可能会根据他们的生活经验建议客户做某事，而那可能并不是最适合那个特定客户的做法，对吧？一个好的治疗师必须具备承认错误的能力，对吧？仅仅因为你接受过广泛的培训，并不意味着你总是会知道什么对你的客户最好。有时我甚至会告诉学生，一旦你认为你知道什么对你的客户最好，
that's a red flag, right? Because even if you have shared identities, we have no idea, right, what this person is really experiencing. I love that. My God, once you think you know what's right, that's a red flag. Absolutely. And it just kind of is like a, I think there's no room for ego or arrogance on either end when you are in therapy. Right. I also like that Alliant does that.
那就是一个危险信号，对吧？因为即使你们有共同的身份，我们也不知道，对吧，这个人真正经历的是什么。我喜欢这个。天哪，一旦你觉得自己知道什么是正确的，那就是一个危险信号。绝对的。这有点像，我认为在治疗中，任何一方都没有自负或傲慢的余地。没错。我也很喜欢联合大学有这样的要求。
Like 50 hours of, like you have to complete 50 hours of therapy to become a therapist. Seems like such a, of course, that's such a sensical idea. And I haven't heard of many programs doing that. So that is very helpful. Yeah. And you can do it. You know, we tell our students, like it can be individual, but it could also be like couple's therapy or it could be family therapy. Like maybe sometimes our students want to go back and do therapy with their parents to figure out with some of these, you know,
比如50个小时的，就像你必须完成50个小时的治疗才能成为治疗师。这似乎是一个，当然，这是一个非常合理的想法。而且我没听说有多少项目这样做。所以这非常有帮助。是的。而且你可以做到。你知道，我们告诉学生，这可以是个体的，但也可以是伴侣治疗或家庭治疗。有时候我们的学生可能想回去和他们的父母一起做治疗，以弄清楚其中一些，你知道，
issues that they want to work through might be. But I think, again, also a good therapist is just someone who's willing to be wrong. Somebody who's really curious and genuinely, right, wants to learn about you and your story versus assuming that they already know, right, what your problem is and what you should be working on. And a good therapist, I lastly say, also always has a map. They have direction of where they want to go with what you are bringing in. A good therapist, A bad therapist, I would say, is someone who's just kind of like listening and validating. I've had friends tell me like, oh, well, my therapist just agrees with me. And they don't really like say much in session.
他们想要解决的问题可能是什么。但我认为，再次强调，一个好的治疗师也只是一个愿意承认错误的人。是一个真正充满好奇心并且真心实意地，对吧，想要了解你和你的故事，而不是假设他们已经知道了，对吧，你的问题是什么以及你应该致力于解决什么。最后我想说，一个好的治疗师也总是有一张地图。对于你所带来的东西，他们有想要去哪里的方向。一个好的治疗师，一个糟糕的治疗师，我会说是那种只会倾听和验证的人。我曾听朋友对我说，哦，我的治疗师总是同意我的观点。他们在会谈中真的不怎么说话。
And that's also a red flag for me. I'm like, you know, a good therapist should be able to also disagree. They should be able to challenge, right? Our job isn't to just like listen and nod. Our job is to kind of go back to one of my earlier points, which was like, we want to interrupt those patterns that are keeping you stuck, and sometimes that requires challenging you. And I just ask that clients trust that we're trying to come from a good place. It's not that we are, you know, trying to pull you around in session, but we are trying to help you think about things differently. So this really leads super well into
对我来说这也是一个危险信号。我在想，你知道，一个好的治疗师也应该能够不同意。他们应该能够挑战，对吧？我们的工作不仅仅是倾听和点头。我们的工作有点像回到我之前的观点之一，那就是：我们想要打断那些让你陷入困境的模式，有时这需要挑战你。我只希望客户相信，我们的出发点是好的。并不是说我们在，你知道，试图在会谈中牵着你的鼻子走，而是我们试图帮助你以不同的方式思考事情。所以这非常顺畅地引出了
my next question, which is I hear a lot, especially from maybe my parents' generation as well, or even just people, actually from everybody, which is I don't need therapy. I have my friends. I have my friends and I talk to them. I think you mentioned like your friends, obviously if your friend turned around and was like, I'm going to correct you or I'm going to tell you that you're wrong, it would probably feel very difficult to hear. I think what a lot of people probably want to know is what is actually happening in therapy that makes it different from just talking to your friends.
我的下一个问题，那就是我经常听到，尤其是可能来自我父母那一代人，或者甚至只是人们，实际上来自所有人，那就是我不需要心理治疗。我有我的朋友。我有我的朋友，我会和他们谈心。我想你提到了，像你的朋友，显然如果你的朋友转过身来对你说，我要纠正你或者我要告诉你你错了，听起来可能会非常难以接受。我想很多人可能想知道的是，心理治疗中到底发生了什么，使其区别于仅仅跟你的朋友聊天？
Like is it, you know, you're talking to a stranger. Why does that seem to work? Is it the talking? Is it the strategies? Is it the knowledge? Or is it something else? Yeah, absolutely. When I'm doing admissions to bring people into the program, we'll ask people, you know, what makes you want to be a therapist? And they'll say, well, my friends have always said that I'm a good listener. And that is, you know, a good quality. That is something that we want from therapists, that they're able to listen. And there's just so much more, right? There's so much. much more training that people need if they really want to practice therapy. When you meet a therapist and you're starting that work with them, like there's a whole treatment plan that they have to create before working with you. And that treatment plan is really what's going to give them that direction and map of knowing how to help you towards your goal. They probably should
这究竟是因为，你在和一个陌生人说话？为什么这似乎管用？是因为说话本身？是因为策略？是因为知识？还是因为别的什么？绝对是的。当我进行招生面试以招收学员进入该项目时，我们会问人们，是什么让你想成为一名治疗师？他们会说，嗯，我的朋友们总是说我是一个很好的倾听者。这是一个，你知道，很好的品质。这也是我们对治疗师的要求之一，他们能够倾听。但还有更多，对吧？还有那么多。如果他们真的想从事心理治疗，人们需要接受更多更多的培训。当你遇到一个治疗师并开始与他们合作时，在与你合作之前，他们必须制定整个治疗计划。而这个治疗计划才是真正能为他们提供方向和地图的东西，让他们知道如何帮助你实现你的目标。他们可能还应该
also have like a theoretical orientation that they're practicing from. And again, that's going to vary depending on if you're working with a social worker, a psychiatrist, a psychologist, an MFT. So there's just like so much, again, like training that goes into it. And another stark difference is that I think friends, even though they are, I think a lot of the times trying to remain as like, quote unquote, unbiased as possible, like they still have a stake in their relationship with you. There's an invest, they don't want to hurt your feelings a lot of the times. And righteously so, they're your friend, right? They're looking out for you. And a therapist. And a therapist. And a therapist. therapist isn't necessarily going to hurt your feelings, but again, they should be able to be in a position where they can challenge you and offer an outsider perspective, right? That also I think sometimes like friends can't. We're kind of looking at things from the outside in. And I think that that is really helpful for people who are feeling stuck versus getting input from somebody who has a lens of like seeing them in their day to day life.
从某种理论取向出发进行实践。同样，这会根据你合作的对象是社会工作者、精神病学家、心理学家还是MFT而有所不同。所以其中涉及了如此之多的，再次强调，培训。另一个鲜明的区别是，我认为朋友们，尽管他们，我认为很多时候试图尽可能保持“不带偏见”，但他们对与你的关系仍然有着利害关系。有一种投入，很多时候他们不想伤害你的感情。而且这是理所应当的，他们是你的朋友，对吧？他们在关心你。而治疗师。而治疗师。而治疗师。治疗师不一定会伤害你的感情，但话说回来，他们应该处于这样一个位置：他们能够挑战你并提供一个局外人的视角，对吧？我认为有时这也是朋友们做不到的。我们有点像在从外向内看事情。我认为这对于那些感到卡住的人来说真的很有帮助，比起从一个在日常生活中看着他们的人那里获取输入要好。
So when somebody walks into like a therapist office for the first time, you're speaking about this treatment plan or this like, just like a framework or they want a direction to your treatment, right? They want to know where they're going. They're trying to figure out, as you said, where you sit in like a broader environmental, social, context, history, all these things. What can you expect as somebody? What kind of questions are you going to be asked?
所以当有人第一次走进治疗师办公室时，你谈到了这个治疗计划或这个框架，或者他们希望为你的治疗指明方向，对吧？他们想知道他们要去哪里。正如你所说，他们试图弄清楚你在更广泛的环境、社会、语境、历史以及所有这些事情中处于什么位置。作为一个人，你可以期待什么？你会被问到什么样的问题？
What kind of things are going to come up in the first? couple of sessions. Yeah, I think a lot of it will be based on the past and then some of it will be based on the present. So usually one of the first questions that I asks is, you know, tell me what brings to therapy now. What is it about what you're experiencing that is making you want to seek help in this present moment? And again, that gives me usually like a good picture of like what is happening in the hearing out. Oh, well, it's because I can't sleep. Well, or again, I keep dating the same guy over and over again. I just went through a breakup.
在最初的几次会谈中会出现什么样的事情？是的，我想很大一部分将基于过去，然后其中一部分将基于现在。所以通常我问的第一个问题之一是，你知道，告诉我是什么把你带到治疗中来的。在此时此刻，你所经历的什么让你想要寻求帮助？同样，这通常能让我对此时此地正在发生的事情有一个清晰的画面。哦，嗯，是因为我睡不好觉。或者，再次强调，我总是和一个又一个相同的家伙约会。我刚经历了一次分手。
And then I'll ask questions more about the past. So tell me a little bit about your family life. And they're pretty open-ended so that the person can really, like, take them anywhere. It's really rare that we're asking, like, very specific, detail-oriented questions because we want to hear your story, right? I tell my clients, you know, you have lived your life for 35 years, 40 years. You are the expert in your story, and I am going to be a witness to that, right? You really are the expert here.
然后我会问更多关于过去的问题。所以，跟我讲讲你的家庭生活吧。它们相当开放式，这样对方真的可以，把它们引向任何地方。我们很少会问非常具体、注重细节的问题，因为我们想听你的故事，对吧？我告诉我的客户，你知道，你已经生活了35年、40年。你是你故事的专家，而我将是见证者，对吧？你真的是这里的专家。
I'm just here to kind of like listen and help you figure things out. So we want to hear that story. Tell me a little bit about what your life was like growing up. And what were some of the messages that your parents sent you around love, around apologizing? How do you think that's playing into what you're experiencing now? So I think, again, it's a little bit of both. It's like tying the past to the present and kind of going back and forth and seeing kind of like where the client lives, again, in the here and now. And I like that you said it's kind of like a write your own story situation, right? It's very much like they're not going to, a therapist isn't going to find ways to trick you. I think that's a big thing. Like that's not going to help them, like trying to trick you into admitting things, trying to, you know, double. cross you or like suddenly make big revelations about your life is actually like therapeuticly
我在这里只是为了倾听并帮助你弄清楚事情。所以我们想听那个故事。跟我讲讲你成长过程中的生活是怎样的。你的父母在爱、在道歉方面向你发送了什么样的信息？你认为这如何影响了你现在的经历？所以我想，这再次是两者的结合。就像是把过去与现在联系起来，来回穿梭，看看客户的生活，再次强调，是在此时此地。我喜欢你说的这有点像“编写你自己的故事”的情况，对吧？很大程度上就像他们不会，治疗师不会想方设法去套路你。我认为这是一个重要的事情。那对他们没有帮助，比如试图套路你让你承认事情，试图，你知道，出卖你或者突然对你的生活做出重大揭示，实际上在治疗上是
unhelpful. So that's just something. Right. I'm sure. Yeah. It's like we're we're not really supposed to wear like the detective hats. We're not trying to catch a lot, a client lying. Like when we're working with substance use, a lot of the times clients will say, you know, like I'm not using. And sometimes they are, right? Because recovery is hard. And our job. And our job. And our job. isn't to figure out whether or not a client is telling the truth. Again, our job is to listen. Again, sure, we're going to challenge, right, if there's discrepancy sometimes, if things aren't matching up, because we want to interrupt those patterns. But our job isn't to be an investigator, right? Our job isn't to be a police officer and tell you what is wrong, tell you what is right, kind of taking on that
无济于事的。所以这只是一些。没错。我确信。是的。这就像我们，我们其实不应该戴着侦探帽。我们不是在试图抓住客户撒谎。当我们处理物质使用问题时，很多时候客户会说，你知道，我没有在使用。但有时他们确实在用，对吧？因为康复是困难的。而我们的工作。而我们的工作。而我们的工作。并不是去弄清楚客户是否在说实话。再次强调，我们的工作是倾听。当然，如果有时存在差异、如果事情不匹配，我们也会提出挑战，因为我们想要打断那些模式。但我们的工作不是当调查员，对吧？我们的工作不是当警察，告诉你什么是错的、告诉你什么是对的，去承担那种惩罚性的视角。我们的工作，再次强调，就像你所说的那样，是专注于
carceral kind of like perspective. Our job is, again, like you said, to focus on. on that story, listen. Some therapists that are like narrative therapists will even say like, our job is to help you rewrite that story, be a co-author to that story, and write your preferred story, right, the one that you want to live. Love that. Big fan. Let's talk about therapy and stigma.
那个故事，倾听。有些治疗师，比如叙事治疗师，甚至会说，我们的工作是帮你重写那个故事，做那个故事的合著者，并写出你偏好的故事，对吧，那个你想过的故事。我很喜欢。我是大粉丝。让我们来谈谈心理治疗与污名化。
Listen. And you're there for heart-wrenching knocking. The world's biggest stage. And breathtaking triumph. In 2026 FIFA World Cup. The knockout stage. Every match, every moment. Listen on TSN Radio.
听。你在那里感受心碎的敲击。世界最大的舞台。以及屏息以待的胜利。在2026年国际足联世界杯。淘汰赛阶段。每一场比赛，每一个时刻。在TSN广播电台收听。
Join the globe. On the road to the July 19th final. 2026 FIFA World Cup. Stream it all live on TSN Radio. Available on IHeard Radio. Something we've said a lot throughout this is, you know, well, your parents didn't go to therapy. and there's a lot of people who come in and they wish their families had gone to therapy and they haven't
加入全球。在通往7月19日决赛的路上。2026年国际足联世界杯。在TSN广播电台直播收听所有内容。可在IHeartRadio上获取。我们在节目中多次提到的一点是，嗯，你的父母没有去做心理治疗。而且有很多人来这里，他们希望他们的家人去接受心理治疗，但却没有。
or people saying, I don't need that, I have my friends. Why do some people and some communities still see therapy as something that is only for people in crisis or something that is unnecessary full stop? Where does that come from? Yeah. I think that that is really just like the dominant narrative that we have socially constructed. in a lot of parts of the world. So I think for some specific cultural, it is just like so taboo to ask for any kind of help, for medical help, for psychiatric help, just because certain cultures
或者有人会说：“我不需要那个，我有朋友。”为什么有些人或有些社区仍然认为心理治疗只适用于处于危机中的人，或者完全没必要？这种观念是从哪里来的？是的。我认为这其实只是我们在世界上很多地方社会共同建构的一种主流叙事。所以我认为，对于某些特定文化来说，寻求任何形式的帮助、医疗帮助或精神科帮助都是极大的禁忌，仅仅因为某些文化
just believe that that is not appropriate. Some cultures will believe like you solve your problems within your family, for example. The only people that should know that you are in pain, that you're in emotional distress, are your family members. So that's definitely like something that I see quite often. And then I think that there's also just like other bigger social messages, like around gender, for example, how we socialize men to believe that they're not supposed to cry, that emotional expression means that they are weak, that they're going to be a burden. And even to women, right, I think that we can send messages that are really conflicting because
坚信这样做是不合适的。有些文化会认为，比如你应该在家族内部解决问题。唯一应该知道你处于痛苦中或情绪困扰中的人，应该是你的家庭成员。所以这绝对是我经常看到的一种情况。然后我认为，这也存在一些更大层面的社会讯息，比如围绕着性别，我们如何让男性社会化，让他们相信自己不应该哭泣，情感表达意味着他们软弱、会成为负担。对女性也是如此，对吧？我认为我们传达的讯息其实充满了矛盾，因为
we do expect women to be emotional and like soft. and nurturing and maternal. And at the same time, we expect them to keep going, right? We overburden them with tasks and psychological labor. And so it's hard, even if you kind of want to get help, to ask for it, because you're expected to keep the world moving, keep your family moving, keep society moving. And so I just, I think that all of those messages that we send people can really confuse them. Is what I'm feeling valid? Is it enough to ask for help? My culture says that it is,
我们确实期望女性充满情感、温柔、具有滋养能力和母性。与此同时，我们又期望她们不断前行，对吧？我们将过多的任务和心理负担压在她们身上。因此，即使你有点想寻求帮助，也很难说出口，因为人们期望你让世界运转、让家庭运转、让社会运转。所以我想，所有这些我们传达给人们的讯息确实会让人感到困惑：我的感受是合理的吗？这足以寻求帮助吗？我的文化告诉我，这
you know, not right. My community is telling me that it's not right. And so it is really hard to get people to finally do it. Again, I'm a victim to that. Like, I didn't go to therapy until my mid, late 20s, I think it was almost. And it was a career that I was pursuing. And I was still nervous. I was still nervous. Like, what am I going to uncover? And is that going to mean X, Y, and Z about me? So, again, I think it's like these just big kind of social messages, cultural messages that we send people. And you'd be surprised because I do think we've made a lot of strides. Like that's 2026, mental health is pretty widely talked about. But we're still seeing so many people and young people even say, I'm too nervous to go.
你知道，是不对的。我的社区告诉我，这是不对的。因此，要让人们最终迈出这一步真的很难。再次说明，我也是这种观念的受害者。比如，我直到二十多岁中后期才开始做心理治疗，差不多就是那时候。当时这也是我正在追求的事业。而且我当时还是会感到紧张。我依然会紧张。比如：我会揭开什么？这对我来说意味着X、Y和Z吗？所以，再次强调，我认为这就是我们传达给人们的这些巨大社会讯息、文化讯息。你会感到惊讶，因为我认为我们确实取得了很大进展。比如到了2026年，人们对心理健康已经有了广泛的讨论。但我们仍然看到许多人，甚至年轻人说：“我太紧张了，不敢去。”
See, obviously a lot of my friends are therapists because we all went to school together, right? You know, I studied psychology. And something I hear all the time from friends will be like, oh, you know, I had three patients just like not show up. Like made appointments and get so close and then just feel like they can't take that next step. And sometimes it takes a couple times to feel ready to kind of take a peek behind the door. So I think the fact that if you're even listening to this episode considering therapy, you, the listener, you have made it so far on that journey as something that is available to you and something that you're considering. For someone who can't afford therapy, because we've got, there's a couple of barriers here. Like, it's difficult.
你看，显然我的很多朋友都是心理治疗师，因为我们是一起上学毕业的，对吧？你知道的，我学的是心理学。我从朋友那里经常听到的一句话就是：“哦，你知道吗，我有三个病人直接没来。”他们预约了，离得很近了，然后觉得自己迈不出那下一步。有时需要好几次才能真正准备好去偷看门后的风景。所以我想，如果你甚至在听这一集播客并且考虑心理治疗，那么作为听众的你，在寻求这种对你开放且你正在考虑的服务的旅程中，你已经走了很远。对于那些负担不起心理治疗费用的人来说，因为我们遇到了好几个障碍。比如，这很难。
There is the internal battle of like, do I do this as the cultural battle of like, if you do this, we will think this of you. And then there's just an availability issue. For someone who can't currently afford therapy, what are some meaningful alternatives or starting points before that becomes available? So if therapy is completely inaccessible, which it is to a lot of people, I would encourage you to kind of look at your current support systems. So I know we also talked about like, well, friends shouldn't be doing therapy. but I would rather somebody be able to vent and open up to another, any other human being,
这里有内心的挣扎——“我要这样做吗？”还有文化的挣扎——“如果你这样做，我们会这么看你。”然后还有一个可用性的问题。对于目前负担不起心理治疗费用的人来说，在能够负担得起之前，有哪些有意义的替代方案或切入点呢？因此，如果心理治疗完全无法触及——对很多人来说确实如此，我会鼓励你审视一下你目前的支援系统。所以，我也知道我们讨论过“朋友不应该充当治疗师”，但我宁愿某人能够向其他任何人倾诉并敞开心扉，
right, instead of carrying this like pain and distress like on their own. So for example, if somebody's having suicidal thoughts and therapy is completely inaccessible, I would rather than be able to turn to a trusted friend and say, you know what, I'm carrying these feelings with me. I think I need help. That is a starting point, right? at least somebody else knows that you are in trouble. Another suggestion would be like relaying, I don't know, some people are religious.
对吧，而不是独自承受这种痛苦和折磨。举个例子，如果某人有自杀倾向，而心理治疗完全无法触及，我宁愿他们能够向信任的朋友倾诉并说：“你知道吗，我正带着这些情绪。我想我需要帮助。”这是一个切入点，对吧？至少还有另一个人知道你遇到了麻烦。另一个建议可能是求助于——我不知道，有些人是有信仰的。
Faith communities can be really helpful in navigating painful experiences. A lot of the immigrant communities that I work with, because therapy is so taboo, they'll tell me, I went to church and prayed about this. I went and talked to a pastor about this and they were actually really helpful. or I went and talked to another churchgoer and they really helped me through this dark time. They were able to bring themselves to access that kind of help before actually seeking out therapeutic services. And again, that is amazing. Like you said, it's a starting point.
信仰社区在应对痛苦经历时真的很有帮助。我合作过很多移民社区，因为心理治疗是个禁忌，他们会告诉我：“我去教堂为此祈祷了。”“我去跟牧师谈过这事，他们其实真的很有帮助。”或者“我去跟其他教友谈过，他们真的帮我度过了那段黑暗时期。”他们在真正寻求心理治疗服务之前，能够先获得这种帮助。再说一次，这太棒了。正如你所说，这是一个切入点。
So I think first just kind of like reaching out to your local network and saying, you know, I'm feeling this way. I need help. Starting there. And a lot of the times my experience has also been that like once people start reaching out to others and saying, I'm experiencing X, Y, and Z, they connect them to resources because there are a lot of resources that offer free therapy. There's so many. And, you know, if any of your listeners are interested, they can reach out to me directly
所以我认为首先应该联系你当地的网络并说：“你知道吗，我现在的感觉是这样的。我需要帮助。”从那里开始。而且根据我的经验，很多时候，一旦人们开始联系其他人并说“我正在经历X、Y和Z”，他们就会把他们连接到资源上，因为有很多资源提供免费的心理治疗。资源真的太多了。而且，你知道，如果你的任何听众感兴趣，他们可以直接联系我，
and I'm happy to kind of point them in the right direction. But it's not impossible. And there's so many therapists who are just like willing again to donate their time and doing good work and just helping people make therapy accessible that we can find a way to get people connected. This is a great segue. Speaking of therapists who want to help people, I also think this is a big thing. I think very few therapists get into this for any kind of selfish reason, right?
我很高兴能指引他们走向正确的方向。但这并非不可能。有那么多心理治疗师愿意再次奉献他们的时间，做着伟大的工作，帮助人们获得心理治疗，以至于我们一定能找到方法让人们建立联系。这是一个很好的过渡。说到想要帮助人们的心理治疗师，我也认为这是一件大事。我认为极少数治疗师是为了任何自私的理由才从事这一行的，对吧？
You have to study for so long. There's so much that you have to learn. I know we spoke about people who come to Alliant and who apply and they're like, oh, my friends just always want to talk to me. are they they they they I'm just such a good listener strangers on the street tell me stuff all the time speaking of like wanting to become a therapist people like that do you do you think that some people are just born to help others in this way or what's your take on that do you think that there are some people who are just like oh of course that is like your purpose I think it's kind of
你必须学习那么长时间。有那么多东西需要学习。我知道我们谈过那些来到Alliant申请的人，他们会说：“哦，我的朋友总是想跟我聊天。”“他们——他们——我太会倾听了，街上的陌生人总是对我说各种事情……”说到想要成为心理治疗师这样的人，你觉得有些人天生就是为了以这种方式帮助别人吗？或者你对此有什么看法？你觉得有些人会觉得“哦，当然，这就是你的使命”吗？我觉得这有点
twofold I think that there are some people that are born knowing that they want to to help others, that they want to dedicate their lives to helping others in some way, shape, or form, whether that's being through, like, being a medical doctor, being a social worker, being a teacher, being a nurse. They just, there's this desire to help, right? And I think that you also don't have to be, like, a natural born listener or good talker to be a therapist. Like I want to empower people that if they were quiet their whole lives, for example, and are just like super shy and introverted, like you can still learn how to be a good therapist.
双重的。我认为有些人天生就知道自己想要帮助别人，想要以某种方式将自己的一生奉献给帮助他人，无论是通过成为一名内科医生、社工、老师还是护士。他们就是有这种帮助他人的渴望，对吧？而且我认为，你并不一定非得是一个天生的倾听者或优秀的谈话者才能成为一名治疗师。我想赋予人们力量，让他们知道：如果你一辈子都很安静，非常害羞和内向，你依然可以学会如何成为一名优秀的治疗师。
If you are somebody who maybe they said, you know, you talk too much in class. You're socialized too much. You're just a big talker. You're very outgoing. You could be a good therapist, right? And so the skill is teachable, right? The skill is teachable. We can train you how to hone in on certain traits and how.
如果你是一个可能被别人说过“你在课堂上话太多了”、“你太社交了”、“你太能说会道了”、“你非常外向”的人，你也可以成为一名优秀的治疗师，对吧？所以这项技能是可以教的，对吧？这项技能是可以教的。我们可以训练你如何磨炼某些特质以及如何
to highlight certain skills. So I want to empower people like if this is something that you want to approach, it's possible. Even if maybe you got messages sent throughout your life, that would contradict that. And I think that there's people who were just born to help. And so if you're both great, right, if you were feeling like I was put on this earth to help people and I want to be taught this skill, wonderful. But if you land on either of the spectrum to know that it's still possible. I guess that's kind of how I want to answer that. I love that answer. Kind of, not going to lie, set you up
突出某些技能。所以我希望赋予人们力量，如果这是你想要尝试的方向，那是可能的。即使你一生中可能收到过与之相矛盾的讯息。我认为确实有人生来就是为了帮助他人。所以如果你两者兼具，那就太棒了——如果你觉得自己被派到这个地球上就是为了帮助人们，并且希望学习这项技能，那太好了。但如果你处于光谱的任何一端，要知道这依然是可能的。我想这就是我想回答的方式。我太喜欢这个回答了。说实话，我其实是故意设下话题
for that answer. Because I was like, I feel the same way, I think. Also, you'd be surprised. Some people who you think would be amazing therapists really struggle because, you know, like you said, like you can't help everybody. Or they're used to dealing with a
引导你给出这个回答。因为我觉得我的感受是一样的。而且，你会感到惊讶。有些你认为会成为优秀治疗师的人其实会遇到很多挣扎，因为正如你所说，你无法帮助所有人。或者他们习惯了应付一种
specific kind of individual who was just like them and, you know, can't apply that to everybody else. Yeah, I think another, yeah, sorry, Another good example of people who have been in recovery, like a lot of people who struggled with addiction. Like I imagine that throughout their life, they were probably sent really bad messages about who they are and their character and whatnot.
特定类型的人——那些和他们很像的人，你知道的，他们无法把这种经验套用到所有人身上。是的，我觉得另一个，是的，抱歉，另一个很好的例子是那些经历过康复的人，比如很多与毒瘾斗争过的人。我想他们在生活中可能收到过很多关于他是谁、他的品格之类的非常糟糕的讯息。
And they end up making amazing therapists. Like people in recovery are amazing therapists because they have that lived experience that really can bring a lot of expertise. And so, again, I think that if you are somebody who's just like really interested in pursuing this, really not listen to a lot of that, like, outside noise and ask, get mentorship, get the training, and, you know, the world is your oyster after that. Let's talk about Alliance, because you went to school there and now you teach that. You've been with them for like, when did you start 13 years ago, you said? How did they kind of prepare you
他们最终往往能成为出色的治疗师。比如，处于康复期的人能成为优秀的治疗师，因为他们拥有能够真正带来大量专业知识的生活经验。因此，再次重申，如果你是一个对这方面真正感兴趣的人，真的不要去听太多外界的杂音，去寻求指导，接受培训，然后，你知道的，此后世界就是你的广阔天地。我们来聊聊阿利恩特（Alliant），因为你曾在那儿上学，而现在你在那儿教书。你和他们在一起大约有——你刚才说是什么时候开始的？13年前？他们是如何为你...
and how do they continue to prepare people to work effectively as therapists? Like what's unique about this program? Yeah, I think it's probably would highlight like three things. Number one is like mentorship. I think something that sets a line apart is like outstanding mentorship because we are a smaller school. You're not going to be in the classroom with 150 people. So the professor is going to know every single student, which I think gives a lot of opportunity. again, for them to get to know you, know your goals, and reach out to you if you were struggling or want extra help.
以及他们如何继续帮助人们作为治疗师进行有效的工作？这个项目有什么独特之处？是的，我想我会强调三点。第一点就是导师制。我认为阿利恩特与众不同的一点在于拥有出色的导师制，因为我们是一所规模较小的学校。你不会和150人一起上课。所以教授会认识每一个学生，我认为这提供了很多机会。同样，这也让他们能够了解你、了解你的目标，并在你遇到困难或需要额外帮助时主动联系你。
I really feel like for me as a first-gen college student, like that's what really made a huge difference for me, was that my professor, Dr. Davis, who's in our Sacramento campus, I was given a shout out. He changed my life because he actually took the time to find out what I wanted to do and helped me answer a lot of questions that I wouldn't have had answered if I was kind of doing this on my own. So I think that's one. Number two is like bridging the like clinical training with like practical real world training. So yes, we like teach you all of the theories. You get really good paper knowledge.
我真的觉得，对我这样一个第一代大学生来说，真正产生巨大影响的是我的教授——戴维斯博士，他在我们的萨克拉门托校区，我要在这里向他致敬。他改变了我的人生，因为他真的花时间去了解我想做什么，并帮我解答了许多如果我自己摸索可能无法得到答案的问题。所以我觉得这是第一点。第二点是将临床培训与实际的现实世界培训结合起来。所以，是的，我们教你们所有的理论。你们会获得非常扎实的纸面知识。
But then we also give you the opportunity to apply it and give you so much supervision and mentorship while doing it. So it's like a balance, right? So you're getting all of your book knowledge and then you were getting that bridge to like actually going out there and seeing clients and applying everything that you know. I feel like Alliance is a really good job at that. And then the last part is like the emphasis on diversity. I think that if you are living in the United States in this current moment, like there's a good chance that you are going to be working with diverse groups because the United States is changing so incredibly fast. I mean, the whole world really is, right? globally and align it does such a good job at preparing students to work with diverse populations.
但同时我们也给你们将其付诸实践的机会，并在过程中提供大量的督导和指导。这是一个平衡，对吧？所以你们在获取所有书本知识的同时，也在搭建通往实际走出去、接触客户并应用所学知识的桥梁。我觉得阿利恩特在这方面做得非常好。最后一部分是对多元化的强调。我认为如果你目前生活在美国，你很有可能会和多元化的群体共事，因为美国的变化速度实在太快了。我是说，整个世界其实都一样，对吧？全球范围内都是如此，而阿利恩特在培养学生与多元化群体共事方面做得太出色了。
Again, we're asking you, are you examining these biases? Our cohorts are so incredibly diverse. Like my cohorts, I'll have like a 23-year-old fresh college grad sitting next to a 70-year-old retired attorney. The cohorts are just so different. and the students are so different. And so they're bringing in that lived experience. They're talking about their stories in class.
同样，我们在问你们：你们是否在审视这些偏见？我们的学生群体极其多元化。比如我的班级里，会有一个23岁刚毕业的大学生和旁边一个70岁的退休律师坐在一起。学生群体就是如此不同。而且学生们各不相同。所以他们带来了各自的生活经验。他们在课堂上讨论自己的故事。
And so you're getting exposure, right, to all of these different stories. And I just, I think that Aliant does such a good job without the professors. I mean, I can go on and on about how well we prepare students for the current landscape. Yeah, I love that. And obviously, flipping to the other side, like there's people listening to this who want to be therapists. what can you expect from learning to be a therapist both at a line and just in general? Yes. So I know I keep harping on this, but really doing that like self-examination is such a big part.
因此，你能够接触到所有这些不同的故事。而且我真的觉得，阿利恩特在教授们的带领下做得太棒了。我是说，我可以滔滔不绝地说我们如何很好地为学生应对当前的局势做好准备。是的，我太喜欢这样了。当然，反过来想，听这个节目录音的人里也有想成为治疗师的，在阿利恩特以及总体上学习成为一名治疗师，你可以有什么样的期待？是的。所以，我知道我一直在强调这一点，但真正进行自我审视真的是非常重要的一部分。
It is painful in some ways, but I promise you will come out a better person on the other side once you take a good look at your story with genuine curiosity and a critical lens. So you'll do a lot of that, like examining your family, examining your past. And then also, of course, like learning different models that will help you really understand how human behavior works. Again, within that relational context. So you'll learn a lot of the foundational theories about human behavior. And you'll learn a lot of those like listening skills that we also kind of talked about today, like how to be a good listener. Because it's so much more than just kind of having your ears open, right? There is a lot of like reflective listening. So you'll learn so many things.
在某些方面这确实很痛苦，但我向你保证，一旦你带着真诚的好奇心和批判性的视角好好审视自己的故事，你就会脱胎换骨，成为一个更好的人。所以你们会做很多这样的工作，比如审视自己的家庭，审视自己的过去。当然，还有学习不同的模式，帮助你们真正理解人类行为是如何运作的。同样，也是在那种人际关系的背景下。所以你们会学到很多关于人类行为的基础理论。你们还会学到很多我们今天也提到过的倾听技巧，比如如何成为一个好的倾听者。因为这远不止是把耳朵竖起来那么简单，对吧？这里面有很多反思性的倾听。所以你们会学到非常多的东西。
the best part is learning a lot about yourself. Like I am a much better wife, daughter, friend, mom because I'm a therapist. Because I'm constantly asking myself, why did this happen? Well, why did I say this? How could I have done that better? Right? So like that self-reflection, I think just makes you such a good human being. So even though it's hard to move through that while you're in training in the end, I think, again, you just come out so much more of a self-aware person because of it. I love that. I've got two more questions for you. One to do with therapy and then want to do purely with you as a person. What kind of inspires you about this field at the moment, like, and the people who are entering it? What is something to kind of look forward to when it
最棒的部分是能深入了解你自己。比如，作为一个治疗师，我是一个更好的妻子、女儿、朋友和妈妈。因为我一直在问自己：为什么会发生这件事？嗯，我为什么会这么说？我本来可以怎么做才能更好？对吧？所以这种自我反思，我认为会让你成为一个如此优秀的人。因此，尽管在培训期间经历这些很艰难，但最后，我认为你会再次因为这段经历而成为一个自我意识更强的人。我太喜欢这个了。我还有两个问题要问你。一个关于治疗，另一个纯粹关于你个人。目前这个领域以及加入这个领域的人有哪些地方最令你备受鼓舞？有什么是你可以期待的...
comes to the therapy space. Yeah, that's a good question. I think, you know, I have the privilege of seeing new waves of therapists come in every single year because I'm a professor and we teach, you know, a different cohort every single year. And it is really inspiring to see so many people come in every single year genuinely wanting to make a difference in the world. Genuinely wanting to be people, people that can hold space for people who are experiencing like trauma and pain. So like just like the fact that we have so many helpers to me is so incredibly inspiring because the world can be a place, right, where there is so much pain and trauma. The fact that we have so many people with a desire to change that to meet it with kindness
关于治疗领域的事情。是的，这是一个好问题。我觉得，你知道的，因为我是教授，我们每年都会教不同的学生群体，所以我每年都有幸看到新一波的治疗师加入进来。看到这么多人每年都带着真诚地想要改变世界的愿望加入进来，真的非常鼓舞人心。他们真诚地想要成为那种能够包容经历创伤和痛苦的人的人。所以，仅仅是我们拥有这么多的助人者这一点，对我来说就极其鼓舞人心，因为这个世界有时会充满如此之多的痛苦和创伤。我们有这么多人渴望去改变现状，用善良去回应这一切...
and warmth and love is so incredibly inspiring to me and wants me to keep going. year after year in terms of my teaching. And then what was the other part of that question, Gemma? Honestly, I think you answered it super well. I feel like I love that. And I love that you, honestly, it would be just such a great experience, just being on the front line of people who you were just sending out to just like help. I feel like that would be a really great place to be right now. It's like, oh, and the world is just so chaotic and awful and just being like, oh, and then here are these people who just really want to help people. Right.
充满热忱和爱意，这对我来说实在太鼓舞人心了，让我年复一年地想要坚持教学。那么那个问题的另一部分是什么来着，杰玛（Gemma）？说实话，我觉得你回答得超级好。我觉得我太喜欢这个了。而且我喜欢你，说实话，处于那些你正派出去帮助别人的人的最前线，这本身就会是一段非常棒的体验。我觉得现在身处这样一个位置会非常棒。就好像，哦，世界是如此混乱和糟糕，然后紧接着就是，哦，这里有这样一群真正想要帮助别人的人。对吧。
I can't imagine it. Final question. This is a question we ask every single guest, and it has literally nothing to do with what we spoke about today. Maybe 1% what we spoke about today may come up in this question, which is, what is one thing you wish you knew in your 20s that has nothing to do with what we spoke about in this episode. Yeah. One thing that I wish I knew was like that my life was just beginning. When I reflect back in my 20s, they felt so finite. It felt like I had to find the perfect partner to get married to. I had to find the perfect career. I had to figure out where I was going
我简直无法想象。最后一个问题。这是我们问每一位嘉宾的问题，它与我们今天讨论的内容几乎毫无关系。也许有1%可能与我们今天讨论的内容有关，那就是：你有什么事是希望自己在20岁时就知道的，并且这与我们在本集中讨论的内容完全无关。是的。我希望自己当时知道的一件事是，我的人生才刚刚开始。当我回想自己的20岁时，总觉得那个阶段非常短暂。感觉我必须找到完美的伴侣结婚。我必须找到完美的事业。我必须弄清楚我要去哪里...
to live. Should I be buying a house? It was just like all of these social expectations that I thought I had to like check off. And that was just so much pressure when I wish I would have just expect my 20s having fun and living life and traveling and exploring. But I just really felt like I had it all figured out. And I wished that I knew that it was just the beginning. And I could take my time finding that perfect partner. I could find my time, finding that perfect career. I could take risks, right?
生活？我应该买房吗？这就像是我以为自己必须打勾的所有社会期望。这给我带来了太多的压力，而我本希望自己能把20岁花在享受乐趣、体验生活、旅行和探索上。但我当时真的觉得我已经把一切都计划好了。我真希望自己当时就知道那仅仅是个开始。我可以花时间去寻找那个完美的伴侣。我可以花时间去寻找那份完美的事业。我可以去冒险，对吧？
Versus just playing it really safe and figuring out. Again, like I just kind of had to get it all done in my 20s. So my message is like, it's just starting. It's going to get so much better. and again, the world is your oyster, and it's just going to be amazing. You know what? I kind of needed to hear that today. I mean, having so many conversations with people about this. And I love when people call on the podcast and they're just like, your 20s is just the start point. So, yeah, thanks for that wonderful advice.
而不是只求绝对的安全稳妥并把一切都规划好。同样，我当时就觉得我必须在20岁时把所有事情都搞定。所以我想传达的信息是：这一切才刚刚开始。情况会变得好得多，再次强调，世界是属于你的，而且这将会是一段不可思议的经历。你知道吗？我今天其实真的很需要听到这些。我是说，和这么多人谈论过这个话题。我喜欢当人们在播客中说“你的20岁才只是个起点”时。所以，是的，谢谢你给出这么棒的建议。
It's exciting. Well, yeah, I know. It's scary, but exciting as well. Thank you again for coming on the podcast. I, like, really appreciate you taking the time. I'm out of very meaningful and busy work to discuss the truth about therapy with us, discuss the stigma, discuss how to become a therapist. Is there anything else you want to say before we wrap up the episode? No, just that, again, I think if you are feeling like you need help because you're not feeling, you know, emotionally well to know that there's always going to be someone to listen,
这令人兴奋。好吧，是的，我知道。这很吓人，但也很令人兴奋。非常感谢你再次来到我们的播客。我真的很感激你抽出时间。在从事非常有意义且忙碌的工作之余，与我们讨论治疗的真相，讨论污名化，讨论如何成为一名治疗师。在结束本期节目之前，还有什么想说的吗？没有了，只是再次重申，如果你因为感觉自己情绪状态不太好而觉得需要帮助，请记住总会有人愿意倾听，
I know it's scary, but do it anyway. Good things happen when you're brave. That's a great way to end the episode. Great things happen when you're brave. I actually just start a therapy again and it's hard at first and then you just experience, it's like a bit of a fong who's kind of lifted from life, even if it's a bit difficult. So we're going to leave so much additional information in the description, including where to find Dr. Espinoza, information about Alliance University and their amazing programs and the way they do things differently and so much more. Thank you if you've made it to the end. Leave a comment down below.
我知道这很吓人，但还是去做吧。当你勇敢时，美好的事情就会发生。这是结束本期节目的绝佳方式。勇敢时会有美好的事情发生。我其实刚刚重新开始做心理治疗，一开始很难，然后你就会体会到，就像是从生活中卸下了一副沉重的担子，尽管过程有点艰难。我们将在节目简介中留下大量额外的信息，包括如何找到埃斯皮诺萨博士（Dr. Espinoza）、关于阿利恩特大学及其惊人项目的的信息、他们与众不同的做事方式以及更多内容。谢谢你坚持听到了最后。在下方留个评论吧。
Are you currently in therapy? I want to know. Leave a comment if you're listening on Spotify. And as always, be safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself. We will talk very, very soon. What's up, fam, it's sports journalist Ari Chambers. Hey, what's up, y'all? It's your girl, Sam J. And we're the hosts of everyone watches women's sports, a new podcast from together. We're breaking down the biggest headlines, the viral. moments and the stories everyone's talking about across women's sports. From game-changing performances to culture-shifting conversations, we'll give you our takes, our debates, and a few laughs along the way.
你目前正在接受心理治疗吗？我想知道。如果你在Spotify上收听，请留个评论。一如既往，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一些。我们很快就会再聊。大家好，我是体育记者阿里·钱伯斯（Ari Chambers）。嘿，大家好！我是萨姆·J（Sam J）。我们是《每个人都在看女子体育》（Everyone Watches Women's Sports）的主持人，这是一档来自Together的全新播客。我们将剖析女子体育界最大的头条新闻、病毒式传播的时刻以及每个人都在讨论的故事。从改变比赛表现的时刻到改变文化的对话，我们将为您带来我们的看法、辩论，并在过程中带来一些欢笑。
Because everyone watches women's sports. Listen to everyone watches women's sports. On the I-Heart Radio app. Apple Podcast or wherever you get your podcast. This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
因为每个人都在看女子体育。请在I-Heart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《每个人都在看女子体育》。这是一档I-Heart播客。保证真人。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击转写中的任意句子即可留下评论。